build compelling dashboards with r
Python and Julia in the upcoming 1.4
release of Cordo you'll be able to
create compelling dashboards with r
Python and Julia this stock monitoring
dashboard was built with fewer than 100
lines of code dashboards are made up of
rows and columns then you arrange them
in a grid and add more advanced layer
outs with sidebars tab sets and pages to
demonstrate how to create a Cordo
dashboard first you start off with your
yaml your title and format dashboard
next you can add code such as greting
applaud as well as text here's some
content next horda has some Nifty
features that you can add such as value
boxes that highlight different numbers
or icons that you want to show finally
when you're done click render and then
your corter dashboard will render